anger
frustration
and a touch of deja vu
for maximal transit target
and
rates of bundesw probably by the end of
this winter pretty much everyone in
germany it has sometimes been said
somewhat cynically will have been
vaccinated recovered or died as we head
towards the winter months is the uk
facing a similar fate
[Music]
rocketing case numbers in the
netherlands here in dark blue austria in
grey and lightview germany is now about
level with the uk but cases are rising
fast these steep curves are a problem
cases are not just rising in these
european countries they're shooting
upwards
large numbers of people getting infected
at the same time means extra pressure on
health services which are already
stretched during the winter months
anyway the combination of that means
more people are likely to die one of the
main reasons the surge is happening is
vaccination rates studies are showing
that getting vaccinated makes you less
likely to not only get kovid19 but also
to die from it
as you can see here the uk's uptake was
faster and started earlier germany and
austria only reached our levels of
coverage in recent weeks there was also
a shorter gap between doses for much of
these countries rollouts there's also
the fact the uk has been offering
booster jabs to top our community since
mid-september and case rates remain
higher than elsewhere in europe during
the summer months
which could mean the uk population is
better prepared for a surge
we have as a consequence of that wave
over the summer a lot higher natural
immunity and superimpose on that natural
immunity obviously is vaccine-induced
immunity
there's certainly evidence for that look
at covet antibodies in 16 to 24 year
olds in england up at around 96
yet only 84 have had at least one dose
of the vaccine compelling evidence of
natural infection topping up vaccine
protection
in austria some other controversial
schemes were set up to entice people to
get jabs with one brothel offering free
vouchers
but with case rates continuing to rise
the government has now passed a law to
make vaccination mandatory from next
february they're also backed into a full
lockdown
germany and the netherlands are imposing
new restrictions to control their own
rates several other european countries
have done the same
but it's been nearly two years since the
word covid entered our vocabularies and
many are simply fed up
it's so sad
hard i'm angry all things
it's the million dollar question but
with many cold winter months ahead it
really is impossible to tell but
scientists believe a combination of
natural and vaccine immunity means we
could avoid a major winter surge
it's not to say here in the uk we
haven't paid a price
can certainly argue we've avoided a
winter surge so far compared with others
but at what cost for months the uk
that's in red has been averaging 100 to
150 covered deaths a day since we opened
up on july 19th nearly 15 000 people
have died with covet
on top of that there's the impact of
severe illness and the drain it's
putting on the nhs
for now the government is sticking with
its plan to avoid further restrictions
we don't see anything in the data at the
moment to suggest that we need to to go
to plan b you know we're gonna we're
sticking with with plan a but this virus
has already proved itself to be
extremely unpredictable so about the
only thing we can be sure of is that we
really can't be sure one thing is for
certain the winter ahead will be a big
test